as sexual allegations become more and
more vague are we reaching the end of
the me to moment plus president Trump's
comments on immigration are polarizing
the country but our Republicans and
Democrats both painting themselves into
different corners I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
so I've got to get you today apparently
writing The Handmaid's Tale is not
enough to get you off the hook with the
feminists you actually have to be a
full-fledged crazy person in order to
earn the love of the feminist movement
we'll talk about that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club so
you have heard me talk before of the
amazing shave that I get using my Dollar
Shave Club razor I use it right here
under my jaw line because in Judaism you
have to use the electric razor above
that but should the razor is just a
fantastic and I use there dr. Carver's
shave butter as well I'm here to tell
you that my membership will remain no
matter what because I'm adding a DSC
products to my daily routine they make
products for your hair your face your
skin your shower everything you need
they have me looking smelling incredible
just ask my wife it's there all original
ingredients they use only the finest
premium stuff they deliver it to you
just like they do their razors and that
means no more annoying trips to the
store trying to figure out which thing
to buy and you get the generic brand it
just use Dollar Shave Club you never
have to worry about the stuff ever again
you can use Dollar Shave Club for almost
anything razors body cleanser hair gel
and yes even their fabled butt wipes DSC
has you covered head to toe and now it's
a great time to give Dollar Shave Club a
try you can get your first month of
their best razor along with travel sized
versions of shaved butter body cleanser
and even those magical butt wipes for
just $5 after that replacement
cartridges ship for just a few bucks a
month when you subscribe you never have
to worry about it again it's the DSC
starter set get yours for just $5
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com slash
gremlins dollar shave club comm slash
men again when you use that slash been
then you get their first month of their
travel sized version of everything plus
the razor for five bucks so check it out
right now dollarshaveclub.com slash been
using the slash pens they know what you
say and get the best shape possible and
get the rest of their great products as
well and I'll say about wipes one more
time just because it's hilarious okay so
now let's begin with the collapse of the
meeting movement so the meet shoe
movement is going to continue because it
should okay nobody is in favor of rape
or sexual assault I have yet to see all
the people out there marching in the
streets in defense of Harvey Weinstein
which demonstrates once again that the
idea that we live in a rape culture that
is fine with rape is I would say wildly
overstated what we are concerned with
and what we should be concerned with is
this feeling
that
more people are now being dragged into a
dragnet of exaggeration and awkwardness
and uncomfortableness the idea being
that if a woman is uncomfortable or
awkward about sex and afterward she
feels bad about it because maybe she
shouldn't have been there in the first
place then we are supposed to believe
that she was raped or wronged in some
way now I believe she was wronged by her
right if you put yourself in a bad
situation and then you go forward with
something without any indicator to the
person that you are having sex with that
you don't want to do this and then you
feel bad later you have been wronged by
you okay that is your fault okay I know
that there's not victim blaming because
you're not the victim except you're your
own victim okay if you say to a guy I'm
gonna come back to your apartment I'm
gonna have sex with you you go through
the whole thing and then the next
morning you feel bad because it was
awkward or it turns out the guy was a
jerk and halfway through the sex he felt
like you didn't like it but you didn't
let him know that you didn't say no get
off of me he just went forward with it
because it was too awkward to say no you
at that point are your own victim you're
not his victim and blaming him for that
situation is no more right than blaming
blaming anybody for something for which
they are not responsible if you don't
get the guy can't read minds
it's so funny we're talking constantly
about mansplaining things like if I
explain something to a woman I'm
mansplaining
feminist splaining is where you explain
to me I was supposed to read your mind
based on the outward indicators that
make no sense the reason this is coming
up now is because as we discussed
yesterday there's a long article in babe
calm about Aziz Ansari this comedian
plays Tom Haverford on Parks and
Recreation and there's this long three
thousand more piece about this woman
named Grace who went back to his ease on
saris apartment engaged in multiple
rounds of sexual activity with him and
then as she was leaving said she felt
uncomfortable and wrong and then he said
well I'm sorry you felt that way and
that was the end of the story but this
was treated by a bunch of feminists as
actual evidence that Aziz Ansari's
should have his career ended that he
should be finished by this now I'm glad
to report that I'm not the only one
who's saying this story is ridiculous
Barry Weiss unburdening our times heard
a very good piece on this over at the
Atlantic there was a very good piece on
this but there are feminists who are
coming out nonetheless and suggesting
that Aziz Ansari should basically be put
away and his career should somehow take
a ding because he a famous celebrity
invited a girl back to his apartment
where she proceeded to get naked with
him and then engage in several rounds of
sexual activity this is
insipid what's particularly insipid
about this is it actually undermines the
foundations of feminism itself the
entire idea of feminism is that women
have sexual agency right the women are
supposed to be able to make their own
choices but now we're learning that a
lot of feminists think that women should
not be able to make their own choices
that men should be able to make the
choice for the woman saying well you
know what I don't think it's in your
best interest to have sex with me right
now so it's not just on men as to
whether women have sex it's it's on men
as to whether women have a good sexual
experience all the way through beginning
to end which leads to bizarre stories
like this one so there is a new app I am
not kidding it's called legal fling okay
this is from daily wire Emily zanotti
reporting worried your consensual
one-night stand will turn into a rape
allegation because you didn't get proper
a verbal and written consent from your
sexual partner well now there's an app
for that the new program legal fling
claims to provide couples who hook up on
the fly with an easy way to avoid being
later accused of taking advantage of one
another an app that couples can use to
create a legally binding contract saying
that both of them can sense their casual
union so we used to have something like
this called a marriage contract it
actually came along with obligations
where you actually were supposed to do
things from one another beyond getting
your rocks off but now we have to have
legal consent forms for you to have a
one-night stand after downloading legal
fling you can send requests to potential
partners who then have the option of
checking off certain boxes like use a
condom photo and video and BDSM how
convenient and I mean does this does
this say love I mean it says love to me
I know that when I'm thinking romance
nothing says romance to me like a legal
app like an actual form that you fill
out with boxes to check every time I
decide to get romantic with my wife this
is what I do I walk in the room I drop a
quick contract as I'm a lawyer and then
I say please sign them and date on the
dotted line and initial at these
particular paragraphs if you're into
this it looks great she loves it and if
you later decide you want to revoke your
consent you grab your phone and
electronically end the hook-up you can
also according to the apps website use
the app to write notes about your
experience all of these notes and
contracts and then maintain securely and
privately using blockchain the apps
creators believe they are solving the
problem of consent issues but legal
flings still hasn't passed either Apple
or Google's approval process it's also
questionable as to whether the contracts
are in fact legally binding they are not
of course because according to the left
consent is a continuous issue meaning
that in the middle of the sex if the
woman says I'm done then the
has been ended so unless you grab the
app in the middle of the actual coitus
then you are going to presumably be be
accused of violating the woman's consent
even if she signed the the contract
beforehand now what's funny is that the
lefties to recognize how prudish and
silly all of this was right there's a
show called new girl with what's the
name of the woman who starts a new girl
Thank You Zoey Deschanel who's famous
for her bangs and she was and in the
show the first couple seasons was
actually pretty funny there's one
episode of the show well which is a
flashbacks he's always prom night when
she is looking forward to having sex for
the first time because this is America
where this is now the big thing is that
on your prom night you're supposed to
have sex too the first time not on your
wedding night on a prom night with some
Rando from high school who has pimples
and is ugly that's that's typically how
prom night is supposed to go very
exciting here in America where
traditional sexual mores have been
thrown away in any case this is a very
funny scene in which Zooey Deschanel
basically is with a guy and it
demonstrates the disconnect between what
feminists think they want out of sexual
experiences and what they actually want
out of sexual experiences because always
a Chanel's character on the show is a
feminist she is a single woman who's
living with a bunch of dudes in an
apartment but this is a flashback to a
prom night and it demonstrates the
stupidity of the apps like legal fling
gonna take off your dress
type your permission yep yeah
I can't find this zipper oh there is no
zipper um I made this dress of my mom's
over again um and maybe I could try
abdominal areas okay yes
you know um because maybe you could just
flip it I just wanna make sure you
feeling safe no no no I I feel like so
safe and like I've never felt like more
safe do I have your permission yes
now I'm feeling very unsafe okay the
reason that's funny is because this is
stupid people okay if this is how you
think sexual encounters are supposed to
go or that any sexual encounter in
history has gone this way you're out of
your mind that's why Hollywood used to
be able to joke about this stuff but now
Hollywood can't even joke about it
because they think that this is the
ideal sexual scenario the ideal sexual
scenario is where you are asking every
step of the way for permission there's
not a woman alive who feels like this is
sexy not one okay if you can name this
woman to me the things that this scene
is like really hot then you're gonna
have to you are going to have to show
her to me because I don't believe you I
think you're lying hey the reality is
that women want men to act like men that
involves a certain amount of aggressive
activity not rape obviously not doing
things that women don't want but if a
man is acting like a passive do nothing
in the bedroom women are not interested
and it's just it's just a lie I'm sorry
it's just a lie if you're acting like
the like the Jeff Goldblum out the Jeff
global the warrior character in Jurassic
Park okay and that's that's your that's
your sexual come-on strategy it's not
going anywhere this is all fictional
nonsense that was created by a culture
that has refused to make any rules and
now is backtracking and making new rules
to fill them the rules that should have
been there in the first place absolute
stupidity okay before we go any further
I want to talk about President Trump and
bleep holes because that's all we can
talk about now using our Dollar Shave
Club wipes we can wipe up this bleep
whole situation well get to all of that
in just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
ripping calm do you need to get away I
do okay that's why we need to go to
tripping coms they're tripping down is
the place to go for your vacation
rentals so I'm in a unique situation
when I go on vacations I can't really
stay in a hotel
because they don't have a kitchen right
i keep kosher that means that i need a
kitchen also have small children which
means i need a washing machine because
they get everything insanely dirty all
the time well that's why I need trippin
comm because if I were staying in the
local high it might be nice but it's
smaller doesn't have any of these
amenities trippin comm make sure that I
can go any place that I want basically
and they have vacation rentals there for
you with trippin comm one search lets
you culture compare sort over ten
million available properties on trusted
sites like the RB o TripAdvisor
booking.com
and more and you don't have to worry
about getting the best deal because
you're saving an average of 18% per
night by booking your vacation with
trippin calm as I say I only use trippin
comm I can't because when I'm booking a
vacation I'm not gonna stay in a hotel
don't forget if you want to save time
and money go to trippin comm Shapiro
today trippin comm / Shapiro trippin
comm / Shapiro go and do that right now
when you use that / appear oh that lets
them know that we set you as I say you
know you you think that vacation is good
cuz you're taking a hotel the truth is
it's much better when you have more room
to spread out it's like home away from
home
it's just fantastic to stay at one of
these nice vacation rentals my wife and
I do it every time I go on vacation now
and tripping calm makes that possible
and makes it less expensive again
tripping calm / appear I'll use the /
Shapiro so they know that we sent you
okay so meanwhile in other news and the
Democrats are grilling on the hill today
the Department of Homeland Security
Secretary woman in Christian Nielsen
about president Trump's alleged
statements regarding immigrants from
bleep whole countries right and they're
growing her did he really say bleep all
countries did he really say he wants
fewer people from bleep all countries
okay we are now in what day six of this
controversy this interminable
controversy where we're supposed to
discuss ad nauseam whether the president
is racist or whether he was just making
comments that were about which countries
we ought to prioritize and we're just
gonna go around in circles on this thing
and everybody's gonna make each other
score each other crazy one thing I will
say when Democrats suggest that they are
deeply concerned about the president's
racism for saying that he wants
immigrants from Norway over Haiti and
they refused to acknowledge by the way
the day before the ambassador from
Norway was at the or the Prime Minister
of Norway was at the White House which
is probably why Trump was saying Norway
and they refused to acknowledge that
Trump said in that same report the
Washington Post report they wants more
immigrants from South Korea which is not
exactly indicative of races
because South Koreans are not white it
turns out that maybe maybe as
possible Trump was talking about a
merit-based immigration system now maybe
he wasn't maybe he was saying something
racist maybe who's saying I want fewer
black people in the United States or
maybe he was saying that you have
created a system by which we are
supposed to judge a hierarchy of
countries than we are supposed to take
immigrants from and I'd prefer to take
immigrants from countries where the
countries are closer to the Western Way
of life than countries that are less
close to the Western Way of life which
again is not that's not racist okay and
that's it maybe wrong because the fact
is what I would like is a merit-based
system where we judge individuals
instead of judging the country of origin
but if you're going to judge solely
based on country of origin of course
you're gonna value South Korea over
Russia for example the South Korea is
more westernized country than Russia is
I've used Russia as the example because
there are a lot of Russian immigrants to
the United States who do really well I
mean my great-grandparents were Russian
immigrants to the United States but
Russia is also a place that's governed
in a very different way has a different
culture and different language right in
South Korea everybody virtually knows
English it's taught in schools I believe
and South Koreans come to the United
States and have a history of doing
incredibly well here so is it wrong to
talk about prioritization of countries
if we are going to talk about
prioritization of countries and here's
how you know the Democrats are fibbing
about all of this so Chuck Schumer was
on CBS's Late Show last night because we
have to have our comedy shows be replete
with politics and here's what he said he
said Trump's comments over and over and
over again can be described as nothing
but racist and obnoxious he says he's
not a racist well I have a challenge for
Donald Trump okay actions speak louder
than words if you want to begin just
begin that long road back to proving
you're not a racist
you're not bigoted support the
bipartisan compromise that three
Republicans and three Democrats have put
on the floor everyone gave and get the
dreamers safety here in America that's
what he should do
in other words embrace the policy the
Chuck Schumer likes and that's how you
can prove that you're not a racist and
that's what I was saying yesterday is
that it seems to me that a lot of what
Democrats are doing here is using the
racism club in order to beat Trump into
a corner on policy and there's a certain
irony to this right Chuck Schumer is
saying that Trump is a racist for saying
that people from certain countries are
going to assimilate better than people
from other countries or that we should
prioritize certain countries over other
countries and that's racist right but
Chuck Schumer is proposing a legal
regime that prioritizes in certain
countries over other countries
if Chuck Schumer really wanted us not to
judge people based on their place of
origin
he should be in favor of getting rid of
the diversity Visa Lottery he should be
in favor of getting rid of country based
origin based immigration systems he
should be in favor of an individual
merit-based system which I am told the
president from pelant's and president
Trump says that he wants so if we were
really all on the same page we're all
anti racism or anti bigotry or anti
discrimination based on birthplace then
we'd have a system that didn't take into
account birthplace wouldn't we we'd have
a system that looks purely at whether
somebody ought to come into the United
States or not on an individual level but
Democrats don't want that and that's how
you can prove than what they're talking
about this is this deep caring about
Trump's and races Trump's not a racist
it's all a lie they don't care about
that they want their policy priorities
if they really care about racism and
immigration they would be trying to wipe
out any semblance of country of origin
being the adjudicate the adjudicative
factor when it comes to immigration
itself but I think that there's
something else going on here too and I
think the Democrats are painting
themselves into a corner so I think
they're doing this on shutdown talk so
right now there's talk of a government
shutdown so Republicans obviously
control Congress president Trump the
immigration deal is basically dead it's
going to be unlikely that there's any
sort of immigration deal cut with
Democrats Democrats have no interest in
giving from any sort of win here but you
could have a government shutdown if the
Democrats do not go forward with the
Republican budget now I highly doubt the
Democrats will do that I think Democrats
will probably go forward with the budget
Trump will sign into law some big budget
just like he did last year with very few
cuts attached it won't include border
funding
it'll basically be a clean government
funding program the same way it was last
year because I don't think the Trump
actually has the intestinal fortitude to
have a government shutdown fight with
Democrats over border wall funding I
think he should but I don't think he
will all that said Democrats have
painted themselves into a bit of a
corner like Claire McCaskill says
welcome to our world
we've got people running for president
all trying to find their base and then
you've got people from from states that
are trying to continue to legislate that
we always have by negotiation and never
the twain shall meet in other words she
is saying that there's not a lot of
interest in actually coming to an
agreement here but nobody also wants to
be blamed for an actual government
shutdown there's a lot of hubbub
obviously a lot of the
are fighting with one another but the
chances that we shut down the government
over all of this I think are incredibly
low there's another way though in which
Democrats are painting themselves into a
corner and here is how Hillary Clinton
got herself in all sorts of trouble
Hillary Clinton lost the election in
large part on the basis of suggesting
that the vast majority of Americans or
at least a large swath of Americans were
deplorable
racists bigots all writers but that
anyone who supported Trump was a member
of this group that anybody who was
sanguine about Trump as president was
ignoring his bigotry nor in a vote for
him that all of these people had to
believe that bigotry and racism didn't
matter making them racists and bigots
and there are a lot of people who felt
like you know what Hillary's a jerk I'm
gonna vote against her just because she
disdains ordinary Americans Democrats
are verging on that when they say that
Trump is a racist they're not just
saying Trump is a racist usually okay
what Democrats are usually saying is
that all the things that Trump has done
are racist right this is the Chuck
Schumer point and if you want to prove
you're not a racist you have to agree
with me but there are a lot of people
who don't agree with Chuck Schumer and
who are not racist right I don't agree
with Chuck Schumer I'm not a racist
hey I don't agree with Chuck Schumer in
fact I think Chuck Schumer's policies
with regard to immigration are kind of
bigoted because he wants to benefit
certain countries over other countries
as opposed to using a merit-based system
right but Democrats when they suggest
that Trump's policies and his rhetoric
are all of the peace that everyone who
agrees with Trump on policy must be a
racist what they are doing is driving
away large segments of the American
population they're making you choose you
can either choose Trump's policies and
his racism or you can choose Democratic
policies and their non racism well what
if I neglected to to make that choice
what if I say I like a lot of Trump's
policies but I don't like a lot of the
things Trump says well Democrats say I'm
not allowed to make that choice they've
created this false dichotomy this false
binary and I'm now supposed to fall into
that trap
the problem is that alienates voters
right if you're a Democrat and you're
saying that you should think twice about
saying that Trump is a racist not just
because it's questionable as to whether
Trump is actually a Richard Spencer type
racist but also because if you're going
to say Trump is a racist you need to say
his comments are what make him a racist
not his policies but Democrats aren't
doing that they're just saying that
Trump is a racist bully and the
implication and I think that all Trump
voters are reading into that I think a
lot of people who are not even from
voters I didn't vote for Trump and I'm
reading into that I think what there
reading that when people say Trump is a
racist what they're really saying is
anyone who agrees with his immigration
policy is a racist right they're using
Trump as a proxy for anyone who agrees
with Trump policies so in Elizabeth
Warren says Trump is a racist bully
she's actually I think painting
Democrats into a dangerous corner
ripping the American population by proxy
Donald Trump is a racist bully and we
know how to deal with bullies we do not
back down we do not shut up we fight
back and no matter what they throw at us
nevertheless we persist nevertheless we
person so of course there's her slogan
who she wants to run for president again
the idea that that Elizabeth Warren is
gonna lead the fight against bigotry
after using native of false Native
American heritage allegedly to gain her
job at Harvard Law School is beyond
insane she's not the only person
Democrats are trotting out again if
you're going to go out and call Trump a
racist you have to use non racist to
call Trump a racist you can't try out
Sharpton okay they tried out al Sharpton
a guy who is legitimately responsible
for for at least helping to incite riots
in Crown Heights in 1991 against North
aDOT's Jews and then again against
Freddie's fashion Mart in New York City
that ended with the burning down of the
store and the death of many people who
are minorities al Sharpton is one of the
worst racist of the last 35 years and he
rose el Sharpton ripping Trump is a
racist you don't have to spray-paint the
n-word over the Oval Office and sleep
with a KKK hood to be a racist if you
have racist policies say racist things
operate in a racist manner you are a
racist period end of story
okay since that part where he says
racist policies that's fascinating right
when he says racist policies that's the
part where Democrats are gonna lose
everybody if they just said Trump's a
bad character I think a lot of people
agree if they said Trump might be
borderline racist in terms of his race
in terms of the statements I think a lot
of people would probably agree or at
least give Democrats the benefit of the
doubt when they say you must agree with
us or you are a racist just like Trump
you're gonna lose the entire population
and now they're trotting out celebrities
to make this case so in just a second
I'm gonna explain to you which
celebrities are actually making this
case apparently it's everybody in the
NBA essentially and they're not being
they're not being coy about this they
don't just believe the Trump is a racist
they believe that anyone who agrees with
Donald Trump on policy is a racist the
Democrats I think this is such a major
political mistake they're making right
now so let's start here with LeBron
James
so LeBron who again I don't know why the
one of us powerful words in the history
of the NBA
has amazing things to say on matters of
immigration I wasn't aware that that
penetrating the paint has anything to do
with making border policy but in any
case here's LeBron James saying that
Trump has given racism an opportunity to
be out again what he's really saying
here is that because of Donald Trump
everybody in Donald from space
their secret racist but now they're
coming out the guy in control has given
people in racism negative racism an
opportunity to be outspoken without
without fear and that's the fearful
thing for us because this was around
everyday but he's allowing people to
come out and just feel powerful about
doing okay so he this idea that Trump
has emboldened racist what he is really
suggesting listen I said this during the
campaign when he was actively appealing
to the alt-right is that Trump should
have done more to tamp down racism but
what what LeBron is actually saying here
LeBron James when he says that Trump has
given racism an opportunity to be out of
the closet then he says I like when he
says negative racism as opposed to
presumably positive racism the idea that
racism begins and ends with Donald Trump
I think is an exaggeration now LeBron
says is not all that awful you know I
think that you can make the case that
the Trump did that during the campaign
but what Gregg Popovich does is it
really is awful and this is where he
says that Trump can't even prove to me
that he's not a racist there's no way
Trump can prove to me he's not a racist
other than by presumably agreeing with
Gregg Popovich the coach of the the San
Antonio Spurs it's insidious
our National Center we have to work on
yeah every time I hear somebody say
there's they're not a racist you know
they are again this is the logic of the
left okay and Gregg Popovich I mean this
is so obnoxious I like Popovich as a
coach but he should really shut up about
politics because this is an obnoxious
ridiculous statement that if somebody
says they're not a racist every time I
hear somebody say they're not a racist
you know they are okay Gregg I'll say
you're a racist how's that you're a
racist now how do you respond presumably
respond by saying no I'm not a racist
but according to your logic this now
means you're a racist so we're now
caught in a night to naves logic problem
where the minute somebody's accused of
being a racist there's no way to get out
of it right because if you deny the
error racist then that means you're a
racist and if you say that you're a
racist then you're obviously a racist so
there's no way to avoid being a racist
as somebody as soon as somebody throws
the charge racist at you we're all
supposed to run for the hills and just
assume that that person is a racist and
then you wonder why Trump won you wonder
why Trump still has a solid base it's
because everyone's attempt to lump
together Trump's base with Trump
everyone's attempt to lump Trump's
policies together with Trump's rhetoric
everyone's attempt to take Trump's
individual statements and then suggest
that it is indicative of a broader
worldview
I don't know that Trump has a worldview
about anything I mean I'm not even sure
that Donald Trump has a worldview about
starbursts
there's a story yesterday by the way
it's pretty great that staffers at one
of the Senate offices were being tasked
with going through boxes of starbursts
and picking out the pink and red
starbursts as a gift to President Trump
which is just astonishing I hope if I
were ever president one day I would
force everybody I wouldn't just buy the
sour patch of jellybeans out for Senate
staffers to go through entire bags of
jellybeans and try to determine which
one were the sour jelly bellies and then
make them give them to me and be like
Willy Wonka's factory and make them owns
my Oompa Loompas in any case it's not
just NBA stars and coaches who are doing
this this silly nonsense bill press
right the the famous lefty he suggests
that trumps base is filled with the
extreme wacko racist this is where the
left is going good luck with this one
gang good luck with this one remember
last week Stephen Colbert suggested that
America is the real bleep hole right
that all these other countries were not
bleep holes America was a bleep hole
because Trump was president the disdain
for Americans who disagree with the left
is really coming out now because they're
using disdain for Trump as the proxy and
I think that this is what so many Trump
supporters and Trump voters are basing
their support for Trump on
I think wrongly in some ways but I think
this is what they're basing their
support on is every time they read an
attack on Trump they read an attack on
them because every time there's an
attack on them it's an attack on Trump
right then what bill press here says is
so indicative of a worldview and
mentality that comes from the left that
everyone can read into the verbiage
right when what's in what bill press
says and then you'll see that people
make the connection between what bill
press said and what Hillary Clinton said
in want to lose it with more it is
saying today about strong and tired of
talking about Donald Trump's base so
he's got 35% of the most extreme wacko
racist I don't know rednecks in the
country and everything this is fine he
can say whatever he wants cuz it pleases
his base he can do whatever he said it
best he could go out on Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody and his base would say
good for you Donald Trump come on
than base now I said before that I think
there is some truth to the idea that
Donald Trump's base is too attached to
Donald Trump but I also think that it is
true that one of the reasons that
they're so attached to Trump is because
they see Trump and the slings and arrows
that he takes as a proxy for the slings
and arrows that they would take if you
were not there that how the left feels
about Donald Trump is exactly how the
left feels about Donald Trump's base and
they felt that way about Donald Trump's
base when Donald Trump wasn't there this
is why I think I've said this before I
think in many ways 2012 broke the
country I think that the attempt to
paint Mitt Romney and his supporters in
the same exact way as the left now
attempts to make Donald Trump and his
supporters is demonstrative of why
Donald Trump won you can only call
people racist sexist big at homophobes
for so long before they finally say
listen whoever they call a racist sexist
pig and homophobe must not be one and
everybody's full of crap and whoever
stands up to that nonsense is gonna be
the guy that I back I think it is almost
as simple as that I think that Trump's
presidency is a backlash I think too
backlash against the entire left which
suggested that everyone on the right was
a deplorable not just when they were
voting for Trump but long before that I
spent my entire life being called the
racist sexist bigoted homophobe I left I
am NOT any of those things and my entire
career is proof positive that I am NOT
those things but the left has suggested
that anyway about somebody like me
already I did not support Trump but the
idea that they that now they're going to
attack Trump I think this is what's
happened I think that people are making
a mistake of logic but it's an
understandable mistake of logic
the mistake of logic that they are
making is they are they are buying into
the idea that any attack on Trump is an
attack on them it isn't but it is true
that the leftists attack on Trump very
often it is sort of an attack on them
right bill press his attack on Trump is
really not an attack on Trump it's an
attack on everybody on the right
Elizabeth Warren's attacks on Trump are
not just an attack on Trump they're an
attack on everyone on the right
including people like me who did not
vote for Trump this is why you see this
grand and ridiculous disconnect in the
leftist media on how they approach
people like me who backed Trump's
policies but don't necessarily think
Trump is a great president or good for
the country in a lot of other ways right
the way they approach that is they say
listen if you really don't like what
Trump is saying you shouldn't support
any of his policies which suggested me
an ulterior motive you're painting
yourselves into a corner Democrats want
to keep doing this you want to keep on
the deplorable stuff all you have
do is keep saying Trump is a racist and
that his base is racist for supporting
his policies not just his rhetoric okay
in just a second I won't ask us how I
think Republicans on the other side are
actually painting themselves into a
corner as well I think everybody's
painting themselves into a corner
because they're using Trump is the
prison for politics but first you're
gonna have to go over to Daly wire.com
and subscribe so for $9.99 a month you
get a subscription to Daly wire.com that
means you get the rest of this show live
you get the rest of the deplorable
Michael Noel's show live you got the
rest of the Andrew Clavin show live when
I say those is deplorable I don't just
mean any supports Trump I mean he's
actually a deplorable human being but
you got the rest of his show live also
you will get to be part of today right
later today Andrew Klavan is going to be
doing one of our world famous
conversations today January 16th 5:00
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific is our fifth
episode of the conversation featuring
Andrew Clavin moderated by hosts Alicia
Kraus subscribe today to be part of the
conversation you can ask drew live
questions which you will answer for
everyone to hear Drew's conversation
streams live on The Daily wire Facebook
page and the daily wire YouTube channel
it's free for everyone to watch but only
subscribers can ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber log in to our
website daily wire comm head over to the
conversation beige watch the live stream
after that just start typing into that
daily wired chat box and then Alicia
will funnel those questions to Drew and
he'll answer them for an entire hour
once again subscribe and get your
questions answered by Clavin today 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific
join the conversation or if you want the
annual subscription get all of those
things plus the leftist Cheers hot or
cold tumbler magnificent to wet my
whistle with it rah I'm revitalized just
incredible so check that out for $99 a
year which is cheaper than the monthly
subscription or later you just want to
listen to the rest of the show go over
to iTunes SoundCloud YouTube please
subscribe to our YouTube channel we have
lots of great videos that come out there
on a regular basis we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so it's not just Democrats
painting themselves into a corner
because Trump has become the prism
through which everyone views politics I
think things have gotten skewed we're
basically living in a funhouse mirror
and we're looking at a funhouse mirror
and none of it makes a whole hell of a
lot of sense so Democrats on the one
hand are seeing in everyone who supports
Trump's policy a mirror of Trump right
everyone everyone who supports Trump's
policies on immigration for example all
of those people must be the tiny little
Trump racist dolls like these little
bobble heads that will have funny hair
that's how the left sees everybody on
the right and the right meanwhile sees
themselves as forced to defend
everything that Trump says because they
feel like it's an attack on them right
they they feel like Trump if Trump is
our is our as our shield then we must be
his sword if Trump is the guy who's
taking all the slings and arrows it's
our job to go out there and defend
everything the Trump says I know they're
people who believe this because they're
in our office right I have this
conversation pretty much every day with
Andrew Clavin and Michael Mills
both of whom have suggested that I'm not
doing enough to fight back against the
slurs against president Trump well what
I say is when I think it's a slore I'll
fight back against it right I've
actually been pretty strong on
suggesting there are two possibilities
on the bleep hole comments for example
but when he does something that I think
is wrong and/or stupid I'm going to call
it out because my job is not to defend
Trump my job is to defend conservative
principles and that includes defending
conservative principles and the future
victory of those principles from
President trumpet from toxify himself
right what I'm scared of and I think
with good reason when you look at the
polls is the possibility that I like a
lot of trumps policies and that if Trump
toxicity smears those policies
Republicans lose the house in 2018 they
lose the Senate in 2020 they lose the
White House in 2020 and then you have
any an era of Democratic dominance
brought about because nobody on our side
had the guts to say I like a lot of what
Trump is doing but I don't like a lot of
what Trump is saying and I think it's
polarizing and problematic right that's
that's I think the fundamental
disconnect here and this is where I
think Republicans are painting
themselves into a corner - so if
Democrats have painted themselves into a
corner by alienating 40 to 45 percent of
the country by suggesting that if you
agree with Trump's policies then you are
therefore a racist just like Trump's a
racist if that's the Democratic problem
and they've alienated a huge percentage
of the population the problem on the
right is that by defending everything
Trump says you're also alienating a huge
percentage of
population what I've said is that Trump
deserves the the every president
deserves the ability of the of the
commentariat to judge each individual
action or comment on its own merits
right obviously we take character into
account and I said during the during the
last administration I thought the Obama
administration was a jew-hating
administration at least in terms of
their policies toward Israel right and
that's very much like the left
suggesting the Trump is a racist the
difference is that if somebody on the
right I think is a jew-hating person
like Pat Buchanan then I will say so and
have said so for many many years
right people on the Left won't do that
with regards to their own but with
regard to President Trump and labeling
him a racist you can take your view of
Trump and his racism and separate that
off from a particular policy and
determine whether the policy is
motivated by animus or whether a lot of
people who support the policy are not
motivated by animus that's I think my
critique from people on the left it's
also my critique from people on the
right just because Trump says something
doesn't mean that we have to defend it
in fact sometimes it's better for Trump
if you're trying to convince him to stop
doing these things if you want Trump to
do better then what you would really
like from President Trump is to continue
with the policies that you like but not
to have to fight a week-long battle over
whether he means that people from Haiti
should not be allowed to immigrate to
the country because quote-unquote all
Haitians have AIDS
it's not a battle that you want to fight
because let's be real I spent my entire
career fighting for a conservatism that
believes in certain principles about
immigration merit-based immigration that
have nothing to do with those sorts of
nasty comments or alleged nasty comments
and here's the trap Republicans fall
into they think that every defensive
Trump is defensive Trump's policies it
is not even Trump doesn't believe that
so Anthony scare emoji right the mooch
he's back on TV and he was grilled by
Katy tur on MSNBC asked about the bleep
hole comments I think the reason the
media likes doing this by the way is
because the media just enjoy saying
bleep hole on television let's let's be
true about this again I mentioned last
week that the folks in the media had no
problem bleeping out President Obama or
Joe Biden there's another instance by
the way that came to mind there was a
there was a story by Jeffrey Goldberg in
the Atlantic talking about Barack
Obama's comments about Benjamin
Netanyahu the Prime Minister of Israel
and Obama called Netanyahu in that
article a chicken bleep and it's the
exact same bleep as the bleep hole right
okay
it's poop right it's the S word they
called him a chicken Shh right dad
that's that's what he did did was that
reported did they report it just my call
is saying like you know if you say that
about an ally of the United States the
prime minister of an ally of the United
States then maybe that's newsworthy so
we'll just say it 195 times in a day is
he n ended no of course not I think that
they they look they just want to drop
the idea that Trump is vulgar in a way
that Obama is not I don't think that
that's actually true at least when it
comes to the language used
anyway the mooch is on MSNBC and Katie
turn grills him and you'll see the mooch
doesn't have a lot of really good
defenses okay let's for this
conversation
multiple people and Lindsey let's
stipulate for this conversation that he
said it don't have to argue about
whether he said it or not I don't know
if he said it but just through this
conversation because I want to make a
broader point if you are in a private
conversation in the White House with a
group of people that you're trying to
get a deal done and you are prone to new
york-style rhetorical flourishes which
unfortunately I also happen to be prone
to why do that to the guy he's there he
said it as you just say but I from
Norway why do they have more merit to
come here than people having known the
president for a long period of time I
don't really think that's what he meant
I I'm not gonna interpret what do you
make us I don't understand his mind
entirely okay so but this is the problem
if Republicans are gonna do I'll defend
Trump but I don't know his mind
I think Jonah Goldberg got this right he
said that if you're spending all of your
time saying here's what the president
meant the president needs to do better
house that house if I have to explain
everything the president is saying if I
have to be the Trump translator if it's
my job to be his magical star trek-like
translator where suddenly I understand
alien languages then he's not doing his
job correctly and the president who
especially for a guy who's supposed to
be this grand communicator and great
Brander I shouldn't you know better than
this and when you do this it makes it it
allows the Democrats to play this game
where they get to label you a racist
particularly if you're a person in a
position of prominence or power and that
does alienate again another group so I
think there are two groups in America
and they're alienating each other and
the question is who's alienating more
people in the middle and I think that
that's a nope
question but here's the thing one of
these things can be solved very easily
and in fact solving one of these things
sort of solves both of these things if
President Trump doesn't make
controversial and silly comments and if
he doesn't make comments that could be
interpreted as racist then Republicans
don't have to defend him and Democrats
don't have the opportunity to attack him
or his base right so in the end the
president shouldn't say this stuff but
the various interpretations buy the
right to defend everything and by the
left to attack him and all of his
supporters on policy both of these
things are deeply polarizing they
pre-existed Trump by the way I think it
happened during the Obama administration
to the best approach here is what ben
Carson the Secretary of Housing and
Urban Development had to say he was
asked about what the president said on
this and here's what he said and you
know I'm a member of this administration
and I don't agree with the president
about everything did it say or of how it
said if the way you say things is so
inflammatory that people can't hear your
message it's not helpful and that's why
I don't do that anymore okay and good
for ben Carson right this is what needs
to happen nikki Haley I know has done
some of the same stuff
it doesn't hurt Trump by the way to do
this I think there are a lot of people
in the right who believe all it hurts
Trump it just it really hurts Trump if
you say you disagree with his rhetoric
you're undermining Trump Trump is not on
the ballot until 2020 he's not on the
ballot
Republicans are this year hey there's an
election this year
there's an election in 2020 as well but
Trump can take it man I mean I've never
seen anybody take as much abuse as Trump
took during the last election cycle some
fair some unfair he didn't just weather
it he won right to this idea that Trump
is this delicate snowflake that we all
have to protect from the ramifications
of his own verbiage that every time he
says something we all have to rally
around him and we must defend the leader
must defend the flag Trump's perfectly
capable of defending himself I mean this
is why he won't get off Twitter
supposedly is because he's fully capable
of protecting himself and again do I
think this will do any long-term damage
to Trump I think he'd be a fool to
believe that these comments will do any
long-term damage to Trump nothing else
has I mean they hit him with a brick
during the last election
they've been hitting with bricks ever
since the Democrats haven't stopped
talking about a Russia collusion scandal
that has yet to materialize based on
which you had supposedly stole the
election with the help of Vladimir Putin
but all of that said like the idea that
I'll tell you what can't take it what
cannot take it and what I mean by it is
is critiques of racism and suggestions
that that you're bad people the people
who can't take it are not Trump can the
people that can that are gonna pay the
price for that are people in the
Republican Party Trump is Trump he
stands on his own he stood against a lot
of the Republican Party itself against
the Republican establishment and he won
he's a very powerful figure and not only
is he a very powerful figure in many
ways he's kind of Teflon that doesn't
mean that he can't lose it doesn't mean
that you won't be down to 35% but Trump
has a way as we saw in the last election
cycle
I've dragging people down in the mud
here's what I don't understand you can't
have it both ways if you are a big Trump
supporter of Matamata Magga forty genius
guy you can't suggest that he's such a
genius that he requires my help to help
him out of these situations and also
that he dug himself this bleep hole
stuck himself in it and now requires me
to pull him out with her up hey either
he's such a genius that he put himself
there knowing that it was a win for him
or he needs my help but not both not
both and by the way I think there's
actually a third out possibility which
is that he's not a super genius who put
himself there on purpose he ends it up
there and he also doesn't need my help
he's fully capable of crawling out of
that hole himself again the man can take
an inordinate amount of abuse and his
administration will survive he's not
going anywhere
and when we get to 2020 we'll get to
2020 it's not like this didn't come up
during the last election cycle for God's
sake I mean the man said during the last
election cycle he didn't know who David
Duke was in the middle of an election
cycle the guy said that a Mexican judge
was incapable of judging his fraud case
in the middle of the election cycle and
then he won so the idea that he can't
that he needs our defense I don't think
is right but I'll tell you what can't
happen if the entire Republican Party
rushes to the defense of bad comments
that does have ramifications not only in
the now but down the line for how young
people think of the Republican Party
like after let's put it this way
afternoon what who do you feel warmer
who makes you feel warmer toward the
Republican Party the mooch or ben Carson
in those two contrasting clips what
makes you feel warmer toward the
Republican brand toward conservatism the
mooch or ben Carson
it's a good Rorschach test I think it's
a it's a good Rorschach test now there
may be some Trump supporters who see the
entire political scene as a reflection
of Trump who think that the mooch is is
better for the Republican Party than Ben
Carson in those two contrasting clips I
would argue ultimately the opposite that
what you need are more people like doing
what ben Carson does saying I like the
policy I don't always like what's being
said and fewer people doing what the
mooch did there which is you know I know
his heart he just talks like a New
Yorker and even if it sounds super bad
that means that I just have to defend it
all the more again things that are
defensible are worth defending and I'll
do that but I think it's a mistake for
everybody on the right to paint
themselves into a corner by defending
everything Trump does on the basis that
Trump did it okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
let's jump right into things I like so
over the weekend it was indeed my
birthday and my wife and I went and had
a delicious dinner at doing one of the
great kosher steak houses in town and
then we went to see the darkest hour
with Gary Oldman so that that's a good
wife who takes you to see a world war
two drama on the on your birthday
so the Gary Oldman first of all the
performance by Gary Oldman in here he
should win an Oscar there's no question
that he should win Best Actor Oscar it
is a phenomenal performance it's a
different Churchill than I think most
people see a lot of people are upset
with it because it kind of portrays
Churchill is sort of a colorful bumbler
and fumbler a little bit whereas whereas
Churchill actually was a genius I mean
if you read anything the Churchill ever
wrote the man was a genius no question
but it does point out something a lot of
people on the right who love Winston
Churchill and think of Winston Churchill
is the constant and in a world of
political you know vacillations and the
fact is that if you had to if you had
sort of like in Churchill so any
personality on the American scene
Churchill was actually I would say less
like Ronald Reagan and more like John
McCain the reason I say that is because
Churchill started off in the
Conservative Party then he moved to the
Liberal Party then he moved back to the
Conservative Party
he'd been responsible for a number of
disasters including Gallipoli which
comes up in the movie in the enduring
World War one he wanted to do an
operation through Turkey to try and
defeat the Germans by by creating
another fronts by going through Turkey
it ended with the death of 25,000
British soldiers in Gallipoli he was the
secretary Lord Admiral of the Navy at
first first Admiral that first Lord of
the Navy sorry at the time and
First Lord of the Admiralty I can't
remember the official title in any case
the movie itself is quite good now there
the problems that I have with the movie
are the same problems everybody has it's
historically inaccurate once Churchill
took over there was very little
consideration of actual negotiation with
the Hun as he liked to call them very
little talk of negotiation with Adolf
Hitler from May 24th to May 28th of 1940
there are some talk of negotiation but
it ended by the time June 4th came
around by the time Dunkirk was was
essentially launched and the idea that
that Churchill himself was divided on
this like he had any moral
considerations about whether to
negotiate with the Germans is largely
exaggerated there's also one scene in
here that is pure Hollywood cheese the
suggestion being that Churchill sort of
had to have his spine reinforced by the
British people at the British people
were like ah let's fight the Germans we
don't want negotiations that's not true
Churchill had long been the guy saying
you cannot negotiate with Hitler he was
continuously the one saying you cannot
negotiate with Hitler but it does show I
think less about Churchill than about
the the fate of the British and what the
mood of Britain was at the time the idea
of what do you do when your entire
country is under attack do you negotiate
and try to buy off the bad guys in the
hope of a little temporary security or G
stands halt even at the risk of losing
thousands and thousands of men and it
does go into the minds of somebody who's
having to make those difficult decisions
so here's a little bit of the preview
it's it's really worth watching the cast
is universally tremendous and an Oldman
I don't know how they do the prosthetics
because the you watch this movie you're
like where is Gary Oldman and that's
Gary Oldman he's just amazing here's a
little bit of preview we must now select
my successor man to tell me well man the
opposition will accept he stands for one
thing and one thing only himself
why have I been forced to send for
ChaCha
his record is a catastrophe
you see your true qualities you lack of
vanity your sense of humor
[Music]
your majesty it is my duty to invite you
to take up the position of Prime
Minister of this United Kingdom
I've speak to you for the first time as
Prime Minister I mean incredible
performance by Oldman it really is great
and and the truth is that Churchill was
kind of a hammy character like the idea
that Churchill was this kind of stalwart
non camera friendly guy thing I want to
be Prime Minister and they say this in
the movie and he's it's right since
since the cradle I mean he is his he
thought his father should have been
Prime Minister his father obviously
ended up having mental illness a lot of
people thought was because of syphilis
but he spends his entire life trying to
live up to his dad and there's a lot to
that with regard to it with regard to
Churchill but one of the things that's
really cool about this by the way is
that if you ever go to London you can
actually go to the Churchill Museum and
when you go to the Churchill Museum they
take you down into the war bunkers so my
wife and I have been there so it's kind
of neat to see a movie that's basically
made in a replica of the of the bunkers
the two people who get a little bit of a
raw deal in this movie are Neville
Chamberlain and Lord Halifax who was the
who's the foreign secretary but the main
points I think are I think it's a very
good movie I I do I know that that's
controversial in conservative circles I
think that the movie is is quite good
okay time for a couple quick things that
I hate okay so the first thing that I
hate is there's a speech that the
Palestinian quasi dictator Mahmoud Abbas
gave he's a terrorist he's in Holocaust
and I'm terrorist who signs checks to
other terrorists to murder Jews he gave
a speech over the weekend in which he
ripped into President Trump he said we
told Trump we will not accept his
project the deal of the century which
has become the slap of the century but
we will slap back and then he said shame
on you this is about Trump he said may
God demolish your house aboutabout
President Trump so this is Israel's
peace partner and the supposed person
were supposed to be signing hundreds of
millions of dollars in checks to he also
suggested quote resistance is our path
to force out the occupation from our
land in other words there will be no
peace talks instead it'll just be us
committing acts of terror and then he
suggested that anyone who criticized him
could go to hell he said about nikki
Haley quote she threatens to hit people
who hurt Israel at the heel of her shoe
and the response to her speech will be
harsher and then he denied that there is
any connection between the Jewish people
in the Land of Israel which is just
historically inaccurate and asinine
Jewish connection to the land of Israel
predates Islam like the foundation of
Islam by a solid thousand and a half
years okay it's absurd but he said quote
they wanted to bring Jews here from
Europe to maintain European interest in
the region
they asked Holland which had the largest
Navy in the world to transfer the Jews
Israel is a colonialist project that had
nothing to do with the Jews okay these
are Israel's peace partners hey don't
tell me that Israel is is intransigent
and won't make concessions to people who
refuse to acknowledge any Jewish claim
to Israel at all suggests that trumps
house should basically be destroyed and
then threatened nikki Haley give me a
freakin break the soft bigotry of low
expectations is pretty astonishing okay
one more thing that I hate so there's an
Iowa lawsuit the University of Iowa is
now caught up in a legal fight because
there's a conservative Christian student
group that tonight a leadership position
to a student who's gay so the university
has a policy that bans discrimination
based on sexual orientation and there's
a ten member group called the business
leaders in Christ well the group says
its membership is open to everyone but
leaders must affirm a statement of faith
that rejects homosexuality the
University says it respects the rights
of students faculty and staff to
practice religion but does not tolerate
discrimination of any times they're
trying to shut down the group this
demonstrates full scale once again that
the tolerance of the left does not
extend to people who do not agree with
the left imagine if this were a Muslim
group and they said listen we're not
going to allow anybody to take a
leadership position in our Muslim group
who doesn't profess allegiance to Allah
do you think that the University of Iowa
shut them down say this is
discrimination that this is
discrimination based on religion I
highly highly doubt it this is
anti-christian discrimination pretty
clearly and openly and if the government
rules against the student group and
suggests that the university gets to
make the rules for the student group on
the basis of you know their
anti-discrimination policy the
anti-discrimination policy Trump's right
to Association and freedom of religion
then we really have reached the end of
the road for both freedom of association
and freedom of religion in the United
States and that seems to be the
direction unfortunately that everything
is moving alright well we'll be back
here tomorrow we'll have a recap of
everything that's happening on the hill
where the Secretary of Homeland Security
is being grilled by Democrats about
bleep holes because that's our new world
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018